on 8 news now it seems like school
violence is a daily occurrence within
ccsd and so are parents concerns yeah so
now school leaders are suggesting some
options to help reduce the number of
school fights and other violent acts
that are happening around the valley
christian gaza shares how one parent
says it's still though not enough
it's the parent's first nightmare but
yet what is the school doing
as a parent it irritates you because
this is getting worse robert diaz says
he is very concerned for his children's
safety at school as more violent videos
like this one go viral on social media
superintendent dr jesus jara stating
violent acts assaults and bullying will
not be tolerated in the clark county
school district you have anger you have
frustration and you have sadness as a
parent we can't do anything for adults
we can't go out there and go wild wild
west is just not going to happen but we
expect
our students to be protected by their
school members there safety is a key
item on this week's agenda for the clark
county school district according to ccsd
violent acts are on the rise 600 cases
were reported back in 2019
405 so far this year it worries me like
there's no tomorrow my son's autistic
you know he's not really much verbal
what's going to happen am i going to
have to worry about a bruise coming on
his arm and someone's going to hide it
according to the school safety advisory
committee's report they're recommending
things like improving security cameras
or installing security access doors at
schools increased school police staff
crisis response training mandatory
reporting for every ccsd firearm
incident and create eight k-9 units
trained in firearm detection ccsd did
not want to comment on thursday's
meeting stating more information would
be released at that time when it comes
to
protecting your child there's never a
lot there's never more than enough
christian casa is live local now